so I've been talking about my three meta
issues in politics for a long time
number one how politics is financed in
the United States no matter what you
care about it's influenced by how
politics is financed number two net
neutrality and media consolidation
whatever issue you care about it's
influenced by media coverage of that
issue and net neutrality and Internet
freedom are a huge part of the media
coverage about issues that we will be
getting and number three is climate
change right because if we destroy the
planet and it explodes it's gonna be
hard to lobby around women's rights or
LGBT rights or education because there
won't be a planet and this week we have
been putting more and more of a focus on
climate on Monday where I interviewed
Joe McConnell about what we can learn
from ice cores related to human caused
climate change and today we're going to
go back to my interview with David
Griffin from April of 2015 where we
talked straight-up in very fatalistic
terms can the world survive the climate
crisis and this relates not only to our
interview about ice on Monday it relates
to the recent heat wave and of course
the broader constant setting of high and
low temperature records over the last
many many many years the resignation of
EPA director Scott Pruett to be
immediately resigned replaced by coal
magnate Andrew wheeler so this is a it
couldn't be a more relevant issue today
and it will be even more relevant
tomorrow and the day after and the day
after the way we're going with the
current administration so let's get to
my interview with David Griffin from
April of 2015 I'm joined today by David
Ray Griffin who's professor emeritus of
philosophy of religion and theology at
the Claremont School of Theology and
Claremont Graduate University and author
of unprecedented can civilizations
survive the co2 crisis the book is so
interesting in that it talks about
pragmatic solutions to our energy needs
but before we get into that give us a
little bit of the background in terms of
the social failures that have gotten us
to where we are today with regard to our
use of fossil fuels yes the whole part
of my book about a third of the book is
devoted
to these problems that you know there's
no problem with the science the
scientists agree almost 100% is more
like 98 99 percent that fossil fuels are
causing global warming global warming is
causing the climate change and that if
it continues then the existence of
civilization is actually in danger and
yet we have this enormous enterprise
known as climate denialism and the
fossil fuel industries particularly
ExxonMobil and the Koch Industries have
spent literally millions up or up in the
tens of millions and over a hundred
million dollars funding groups around
the world primarily in America but also
other places of the world to constantly
claim that the the worry about climate
change is a hoax and that we shouldn't
be worried and actually fossil fuels are
good for us and that and so on and and
corporate media has been quite complicit
in this have they not I mean with regard
to the kind of false balance game they
play we're in spite of the 99 to 1
percent consensus you talk about among
scientists they will have one guest with
the hoax point of view and one guest
with the science point of view sort of
presenting this as a as a real 50/50
controversy that's right John Oliver did
a great show one night where instead of
having one on one like that he said
let's have a representative debate and
so he brought out his climate denial
and then brought and and then the
climate scientist and then said now we
need to get this appropriate and so he
brought on one more denial and then
ninety-seven more scientists and so if
you had a debate going on like that you
know ninety eight to two it would be
much more accurate the way it is but
they try to maintain that there's a real
debate within the scientists and and
that's just a lie there is no debate
whatsoever there are details but there
are no there's no significant debate and
the few climate scientists who do mouth
that other point of view we found out
they've been funded funded by ExxonMobil
and other fossil fuel industries so yes
I think I argue in the book that the the
major problem the ones who are major
primarily a fault here are the the media
the the major media because you know the
fossil fuel industries they do what they
are supposed to do they're supposed to
make money and so they're doing their
job and now it's they're doing it at the
risk of destroying civilization but
nevertheless they're doing what they
normally do but the media they are
supposed to give us some sort of
objective presentation of the facts and
what the dangers are and so on and they
simply haven't done it you've got one
major exception and that's the Guardian
which is both UK and American network
but not not network but station and
newspaper and they actually recently
have launched a campaign along with
three fifty.org to really ramp it up to
get this somewhere in the level at
oughta be where we should be presented
with this evidence every day and not
once every few weeks about this so
that's the problem so that gives us I
think some good context and for most of
our audience understands that part the
ones that don't probably are are not
going to be convinced by our
conversation so let's address what I
think your book does in a really
interesting way which is talking about
solutions in a transition to clean
energy from dirty energy you say in the
book that you think that by 2035 we
could have in the US and worldwide 70%
of our energy come from clean energy
sources and even 100 percent by 2050
both US and worldwide so walk us through
this first of all what forms of energy
would make that up well the two most
important thus far our solar energy and
wind energy and part of the lie of the
fossil fuel corporations is to tell us
oh well you know they're nice they it's
sweet to have those things but really
they can't do much to take care of our
energy needs well that was going I'm
glad that you're addressing this that
was going to be my question the the
detractors say solar power is not nearly
advanced enough to truly have the
efficiency needed to provide a
significant portion of our energy and
wind is also just not efficient enough
it's only a drop in the bucket do you
refute that yes and actually even right
now we could be you know if we've been
working on this the way we should have
been over the last decades
we could have most of our energy
provided by clean energy and the other
lie they have continued to spread is
that it will be much too expensive to
use clean energy rather than coal and
natural gas and oil and actually the the
costs have gone down so dramatic the
costs for solar energy and wind energy
that there are some places even apart
from any subsidies the the clean the the
wind and the solar energy are in certain
places less expensive already well if we
were doing what we should be doing that
is not subsidizing fossil fuels
you know we're subsidizing it ten times
as much as we do clean energy it's just
crazy so that's a key point I think that
a lot of people don't realize when you
hear the cost comparisons per unit of
energy produced it's not being
considered that the cost we cite the low
cost we talked about with fossil fuels
is one that is already subsidized by the
government that's right and you know
normally subsidies are for the sake of
encouraging things that we want people
to use and discouraging things we don't
want them to use well clearly we don't
want more fossil fuel energy and more
carbon dioxide going into the atmosphere
and the ocean and yet nevertheless our
subsidy rates is ten to ten to one on
the on the other side it's just nuts and
so if we were just not subsidizing
either side neither the clean nor the
dirty energy it would we would
immediately start making the big
transition because
if you start factoring in the health
costs of coal for example and and and
also natural gas they they they're
claiming that it's so clean it's it's
not much better than coal if if any all
together all things considered and so if
we could just get rid of the subsidies
that would take care of big part of the
problem and then if we also did what we
should be doing that is taxing a carbon
and all economists agree on this even
the most conservative economists agree
that fossil fuels should be taxed so if
we did those we could we could transfer
over yeah so the the 2030 or 35
projection that could happen very
quickly we have very limited time left
but one more thing I want to get your
thoughts on is what what is the most
important step 1 and step 2 here we see
some transition to electric vehicles for
example but the electricity is still
coming but more than likely from a dirty
energy source is that still how we
should be working kind of go from the
ground up first get the cars off of
gasoline then get the electricity that
powers them off of dirty energy or is
there another way to work this well you
wouldn't want to stay first and then
this they they need to be done
simultaneously and and and they're you
know
equally important and if we could take
care of the two problems the lack of a
carbon tax and then the getting rid of
the subsidies for dirty energy then that
would take care of that both for
electricity and for the
home house home heating and businesses
buildings but also automobiles and and
trains and even airplanes are moving in
in that direction and so we could do
this if we had more of a level playing
field and then if besides the level
playing field we had a carbon tax you
know the the the technology it is coming
along very quickly in all of these areas
and once the price is adjusted to to be
what it ought to be it'll go much much
faster we've been speaking with David
Ray Griffin the book is unprecedented
consider TLAs ation survived the co2
crisis very very interesting book thanks
so much for joining us